this is Startalk coming from Facebook
this is Sylvain boot igni oh yes I would
be interested in having your insights
about genetically modified animals and
how important they may be for basic
research as well as the pharmaceutical
industry now you are opening up a whole
nother can of worms here buddy
cuz we're talking about animals plants
our intention animals feelings so where
do you stand bill plants are in sentient
bring it on charge they don't think they
don't think far as we know that's right
well as far as we know that's right you
ever see the original movie the thing oh
it's good I think I did imagine no heart
no feelings a perfect creature and it's
because the thing is like this vegetable
deal alright so we do genetically modify
animals and this retirement lab rats
that glow-in-the-dark the little mice or
that mouse with the ear on its forehead
yeah yeah so these are very important to
our research these are very important to
the way humans know our genes and on
balance I'm in favor of it and I'm not a
vegetarian maybe one day soon I will be
become one no no you won't well maybe I
mean but you love bacon too much
I mean maybe but I understand we know we
raise animals to kill them and eat them
routinely so we buy analogous analogy we
raised especially mice for laboratory
studies that that enable wonderful
things with that said I am very
sympathetic to the idea that there's a
there's a line that you draw right and a
rhesus monkey is like very similar in to
me in many ways superior to my old boss
so I can understand what you don't want
to do experiments on on that guy
yeah you met him you know who I'm
talking about
so I kid because I love
that's hilarious if you're one of my old
bosses out there just notice that
consider yourself an amalgam you are the
Olin for Bill Nye the old bosses is a
mixture of many characteristics of
people for whom I worked and I remind
you all composite man yes as a manager
myself nowadays people don't quit jobs
quit bosses so with that said I think
it's still very important for humankind
to have access to these so-called
laboratory models
that's the now and they use to describe
these rats and mice okay that we have
whose genes we have modified to
understand our own genes so now let that
being said okay so you do you're saying
that it is important should there be a
push like a very specific kind of push
for it
should there be a push to find a
different way or here's my here's my
father one to genetically modify these
animals so that as you work on them they
feel no pain or like you understand me
like I do suppose you could genetically
modify a mouse so that the pain
receptors a mouse is born with no pain
receptors
therefore it never knows any type of
physical suffering because it can never
feel that should that be the way that we
handle it so that's a hard question
Chuck because I don't know that you can
prove that a mouse would never do that
Plus would it really be a mouse and
would it be a good model for a human
after you changed it and so the example
I give you is I know a guy not too well
but I know a guy who's in his 30s who
wants to have his head frozen so that in
centuries hence they can unfreeze his
head and connect it to some future
unfrozen head machine and he will then
be able to conduct his life and
experience life three centuries from now
with that said after you do that
you really replicate the brain combined
with the central nervous system now
we're talking about mice in a laboratory
right and so I I believe that like try
to talk without moving your hands even
when we're on the radio hey there's
something going on between there's
feedback between your distant nerve
endings and your brain and so I think if
you were to modify a mouse so that it
felt no pain I'm not sure it would still
be a good model for a person there's
people I'm sure who'd think deep
thoughts about this right but I don't
know the answer yes and those people are
heads in a jar look at that
all right well listen that was a really
thought-provoking question Silvan or
sylvain and we appreciate you for that
this is Startalk